so we had a problem for 30 or 40 years
where we've not been building up homes
in this country that's the fundamental
solution whether you're looking to buy a
home or looking to rent a home housing
has become more and more unaffordable
and the consequence that is for ordinary
working people finding it harder and
harder to get by so the fundamental
thing we're going to do in the white
paper on Tuesday is set out a plan to
get this country building the homes that
we desperately need you're talking about
building more homes but successive
governments have said exactly the same
thing why should we believe you this
time when we should wait and see the
results of the action I can understand
the skepticism but I'd say three things
first of all if you look at our record
since 2010 when we took over house
building this country was at the lowest
level since the 1920s we've got up now
to 190,000 a year not good enough but a
lot of progress secondly we're doubling
the capital budget on housing Chancellor
gave us a lot more money in the autumn
statement but thirdly I hope that when
people see the white paper they'll see
that it's trying to tackle this problem
from every angle looking at how do we
get more land released how do we speed
up when someone gets Planning Commission
actually getting spades in the ground
getting the homes built and what can we
do to diversify the market because at
the moment we're far too dependent on a
small number of large developers so
we're trying to tackle every area of the
problem so you're still standing by that
target to build a million homes by 2020
yet so that's that's a clear target that
we have and if you look at what we
achieved in 2015-16 we were at 190
thousand a year so we were just just
behind where we need to be and this
white paper is going to set out an
ambitious package to try and get the
levels of house building higher still
but it's going to have to be ambitious
if you're going to hit that target what
are you prepared to do you prepared to
build on green belt land so lonely I
think there's no one silver bullet
solution here if you're going to solve
this problem if there was an easy answer
to it one of the previous governments
over the last 30 or 40 years would have
found it so what you actually need is a
lot of different policies tackling this
issue at every angle of that's all I
think is going to be a green belt then
what well on green by actually we had a
clear manifesto commitment there to
protect the green belt policy is very
clear which is you should only take land
out of the green belt in exceptional
circumstances so I think the reasonable
thing to say to councils is you should
look at every other option in terms of
where homes should be built because
people value the green belt but the
package is going to be ambitious and the
Prime Minister is very clear when she
stood outside number ten Downing story
that she wants to build a country that
works for everyone and you can only do
that if you fix our broken housing
market so it does sound like you're not
prepared to go into battle with the
council's overbuild young green belt
well I don't think you have to build on
you don't have to take huge amounts of
land out the green belt to solve this
problem the green belts thirteen percent
of the country there's a lot of land out
that we can build on we can look to see
what we can do to make better use of the
land we've already got you look behind
me here you can see new development
that's going up on what was previously
brownfield vacant land so can we get can
we get land that's previously been used
back into active use there are lots of
other things we can do and I think
there's a sort of slightly false choice
that's portrayed here that the only way
to solve the housing problem we have in
this country's to build on huge waves of
the green but we don't need to do that
we spent a lot of time talking about
people buying their own homes but this
isn't just about helping middle-class
kids get on the housing ladder the
housing crisis is also about rents so
what are you going to do about that so
it's two things out it's not just
middle-class kids that want around their
own home so the government should
rightly do everything it can to help
people that work hard get on the ladder
where they're from a middle class or a
working-class background but you're
absolutely right if you want a housing
policy that works for everyone you've
got to have something to say to those
people that are renting as well as those
people that want to own and there's a
really good package in the white paper
around that trying to make rented
accommodation more affordable by
increasing the supply of rented
accommodation and also taking action
against letting agent fees which are a
major barrier when people move but also
trying to make it more secure most of
the private sector tennis which have in
this country are just for six months and
what we want to do is get new
institutional investment into the
private rented sector that offers longer
family-friendly tendencies and we want
to work both with big financial
institutions but also those housing
associations that build market rented
housing to do that and the white papers
got a lot to say about that
constructions and industry that relies
heavily on e workers and we're going to
need more of these people not less if
you do want to build all these new homes
so after brick city you prepare to look
at visa programs to encourage more
construction workers into the UK so
you're quite right we're going to need
lots more people in this industry to
build the homes we need and I think
we've got to look at a range of ways of
doing that so first of all we needed a
much better job in our schools and
colleges of promoting construction as an
industry and we also got to look at what
what industry can do to train people up
the new apprenticeship levy that's
coming in we've also going to look at
changing the way that we build homes in
this country so looking at modern
methods of construction that require
different skills and a not so
labor-intensive that can be part of the
solution but then yes absolutely if
haven't done all of those things were
short of skills then our new immigration
policy as we leave the EU needs to make
sure we can we can bring in the skills
we need